NARRATOR: In the 19th Century
anywhere from 10,000 to
30,000 orphan children
lived in New York City.
Charles Brace had a solution.
Send these orphans by train
to small towns across America
and put them up for adoption.
Over the course of 75
years, the orphan trains
brought more than 200,000
abandoned children
to new homes.
In 1848, Charles Loring
Brace arrived in New York
on a mission, to aid New York's
poor immigrant population.
After graduating
divinity school,
Reverend Brace worked at
the Five Points Mission,
a charitable organization
in one of the city's poorest
neighborhoods that also became
a home for its orphan children.
In 1853, Brace founded
the Children's Aid
Society, an organization
still active today.
New York had as many as
30,000 orphans, almost 6%
of the entire
population of the city.
But at the time,
the label of orphan
didn't just apply
to the parentless.
Some families just couldn't
take care of their children
in the harsh conditions
of New York's slums.
Many of these orphans were
children of recent immigrants
who, if they could find
jobs, were forced to take
dangerous, low-paying work.
Dying on the job
was not uncommon.
Dying at home was
also not uncommon.
These immigrants mostly lived
in cramped, unsanitary tenements
where disease easily spread.
Their children could be
orphaned if one parent died
and the other couldn't
care for them.
Sometimes both living parents
gave up their children simply
because they didn't
have the resources
to ensure their survival.
Reverend Brace recognized
that the best chance
for those orphaned was not
in the asylums and juvenile
prisons where they were normally
sent, but with actual families.
So under the Children's Aid
Society, he hatched a plan.
Orphaned, homeless children
at least six years old,
which was considered
working age,
would be placed
on trains heading
out to America's farmlands.
The hope was that they would
be adopted by new families
and grow up in a more
peaceful rural setting, away
from the dangers of the city.
[train whistle blows]
The first orphan
train left in 1854--
42 children bound for
apple-picking country
in Michigan.
All orphan trains were
supervised by a Western agent,
who was responsible for
picking the small towns
where the children had the
best chance of being adopted.
The agent would bombard the
town with advertising banners
and pamphlets
announcing the orphans'
arrival and their
availability for adoption.
On the day the orphans
arrive, interested families
would gather at the town
hall, courthouse, or theater
to inspect the
potential adoptees.
Children were placed on a
stage or elevated platform,
physically put up for adoption.
They were poked and
prodded, examined
thoroughly for their health
and physical capabilities.
Once potential parents
made their selections
and the selection committee of
prominent townsfolk approved,
the orphans were handed over.
Families were only
allowed to take one child.
So any siblings
traveling together
would almost always
become separated.
Any children left over would
move on to the next town.
In their new homes, the freshly
adopted orphans were encouraged
to forget their past
lives in New York
completely, and in some cases,
adopt the religious beliefs
of their new families.
Most learned farming skills.
But some families treated
their new children
more as indentured servants,
sometimes accompanied by abuse,
which often went unchecked by
the Children's Aid Society.
So what happened to these
orphan train children?
Like their childhoods,
their adulthoods varied.
The program produced
many successes,
including two future
governors who traveled
on the same orphan train.
But the notorious outlaw
Billy the Kid also
rode west on an orphan train.
In 1910, a survey concluded
that 87% of the orphans
had "done well," although
the term "done well"
was not clearly defined.
The orphan train ceased
operating in the 1920s,
as federal, local,
and state governments
enacted new child labor laws
and assumed control for the care
of orphan children.
But the work of Charles Brace
and the Children's Aid Society
lives on.
The program helped
lay the groundwork
for America's modern
foster care system,
tasked with caring for more
than 400,000 children today.